I am putting pie and welcome to dist
infinity dammit
so what's awesome about this game is
that you can build whatever you want
so by demonstrate I will now build the
coolest ramp in the entire universe
nailed it
welcome to my town brace welcome to our
town
this is bro Ville whoa actually get it I
want to thank my mom I want to think
Thor I mean I am Thor yes
I've built it now I don't know why I did
this this is my greatest creation of all
chat oh god I'm getting dizzy and Thor
go in a helicopter this is how we ride a
helicopters in Sweden oh yeah seriously
yeah I make it stop make it stop
alright let's build a racetrack let's go
baby woo
oh god ah ah
make it stop it's my own two racetrack
but I haven't mastered it yet not even
close
are they're so cute oh they're so cute
hey come here we must make it as cool as
possible
flowers check not sure if this is
possible nope
yes we're alive here we go
yes yes there we go I did it Oh ah damn
it
hello beers let's go to an adventure gah
mr. beer bears don't have parachutes now
for the moment you've all been waiting
for helping out yes yes that's exactly
what I wanted good thing I wore the
seatbelt
alright breasts what I want to do is I
want to play your creations I want to
play through your toy boxes in this game
for a video I think that will be really
fun and really cool so for me to find
your game and for you to share it online
what I want you to do is once you're
done creating it you go to save and then
you create a new save and you want to
make sure that you name it first you
ride PewDiePie do a space do a - do a
space and then name it whatever you want
and hit done
hit it make a description hit square to
save yes now that's not it for me to
actually find the map there's one more
thing you need to do go down to online
slash multiplayer go to community
content go to submit to Disney and then
find the map
Peter Piper tastic hit upload and it's
forever in the public eye to be judged
by everyone congratulations
alright like I said it's gonna be
awesome to play through your Bros
creations and toy boxes I'd really love
this game and I think you bros would
love it too so make something with ducks
make something with barrels make
something completely random I don't know
but I'm looking forward to play it hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please leave a like and I will see you
in the next one as always thank you for
watching stay awesome bros also bros i
forgot to mention the contest is for two
weeks yeah ma